y
[Música]
brasil superó los 300.000 muertos por
jóvenes 19 lo que generó un cambio de
discurso radical del presidente ya ir
bolsonaro que anunció un comité para
atender la crisis sanitaria y afirmó que
primero es la vida dando una aparente
marcha atrás en su controvertida gestión
de la pandemia
el presidente de eeuu joe biden en cargo
a la vicepresidenta cámara sabes de
dirigir las acciones para frenar la
crisis humanitaria desatada por la
llegada de migrantes a la frontera sur
en un momento en el que en eeuu a más de
14.000 menores de edad que han cruzado
solos la frontera
corea del norte probó dos misiles
balísticos de corto alcance lo que
supone su segunda prueba de armas en una
semana y envía un mensaje más
contundente a seúl y washington que han
expresado su preocupación por este
lanzamiento los proyectiles llegaron
hasta las aguas del mar de japón
muy buen día bienvenidos a las noticias
en france 24 si raúl blanco como siempre
un gusto saludarlos comenzamos en brasil
que supera los 300.000 muertos en medio
de una crisis sanitaria sin tregua por
cuenta de la pandemia de hobbits 19 ante
este panorama el presidente de air
bolsonaro anunció el establecimiento de
un comité interinstitucional para
atender la emergencia los nuevos datos
anunciados por el ministerio de salud
dejan a brasil como la segunda nación
más afectada en el mundo por detrás de
eeuu y la primera en américa latina'
ahora bolsonaro se ha mostrado a favor
de un cambio en su política sanitaria
con la finalidad de controlar el brote
de coronavirus un cambio de tono pues
durante toda la pandemia ha sido un
confeso negacionista del covent 19 a
pesar de haber sufrido la enfermedad en
su nuevo discurso y después de un año
habla de la vida en primer lugar
a la vida en primer lugar resolvimos
entre otras cosas que se creara una
coordinación conjunta con gobernadores
así como el presidente del senado
federal
y es que varios estados federados en
brásil enfrentan el peor colapso
sanitario de su historia en río de
janeiro hay casi 500 enfermos esperando
una cama en el hospital el informes de
baleares a conil y su reloj
por fuera parece un día tranquilo pero
un piso más arriba se trabaja
contrarreloj para conseguir plazas en
las unidades de cuidados intensivos
estamos gestionando nuevas camas para
tener la demanda vinicius trabajar de
sol a sol para salvar vidas
río de janeiro suma 20.000 muertos de
los 300.000 registrados en todo el país
en las últimas dos semanas la media de
fallecidos creció un 67 por ciento
este equipo hace la captación de plazas
identifica las camas vacías en nuestra
red y las pone a disposición para los
médicos reguladores
lo que nos preocupa desde el inicio de
la pandemia es que el aumento de casos
se ha abrupto se ha todo a la vez
desde esta central los enfermos más
graves son enviados a hospitales como
este que es una referencia en la región
aquí los pacientes intubados son cada
vez más jóvenes
había muchas camas vacías que se han
llenado en las últimas dos semanas lo
que acontece muchas veces es que el
paciente no consigue llegar hasta
nosotros por una cuestión de
vulnerabilidad familiar o social tener
habilidades sociales no conseguí
ingenieros en ellos no consiguen tener
acceso a los servicios sanitarios
entonces no tenemos la noción real de
los casos que están aconteciendo porque
muchos de ellos ni conseguimos tratarlos
muchos pueden morir antes en sus casas
otra preocupación es la posible falta de
oxígeno
esta empresa abastece los principales
hospitales públicos y privados de río
están en contacto permanente con las
autoridades sanitarias para poder
satisfacer una demanda que crece cada
día es persona gotas espero que no haya
un colapso en río pero si lo hay
vamos a traer oxígeno desde otras
ciudades que están mejor para darnos
este apoyo a los dos y eso por seguir el
viernes rio de janeiro empieza un lock
down de 10 días para intentar contener
el avance de la pandemia para ello es
necesario que los ciudadanos colaboren y
que las playas queden así desiertas
la vicepresidenta de eeuu cámara javi se
asumirá la misión de frenar la migración
irregular desde centroamérica hacia su
país y la coordinación con el salvador
honduras y guatemala para combatir los
problemas de violencia y corrupción que
provocan la huida de sus ciudadanos
hacia el norte el presidente yo vaya
inició el anuncio y describió a harris
como la persona más cualificada para ese
trabajo en respuesta a su nombramiento
javier se reconoció que no hay duda de
que existe una situación compleja y
habló de la necesidad de fortalecer la
frontera mientras se refuerza la
relación con los países del triángulo
norte y se estimula la colaboración con
el sector privado
la vicepresidenta acordó entre muchas
otras cosas y lo agradezco liderar
nuestro esfuerzo diplomático y trabajar
con esas naciones para aceptar a los
repatriados y mejorar la aplicación de
la ley de inmigración en sus fronteras
debemos abordar las causas fundamentales
que hacen que las personas hagan la
caminata para venir aquí y espero
participar en las acciones diplomáticas
con el gobierno el sector privado la
sociedad civil y los líderes del
salvador guatemala y honduras y es que
el flujo de migrantes centroamericanos o
que intentan llegar a eeuu no se detiene
el drama de padres que se dan por
vencidos y se entregan a la patrulla
fronteriza atiborren los centros de
detención de atención mientras que en
los albergues para menores que viajan
solos aumentan algunos intentan también
olvidar con deporte las penas que los
llevaron a huir
sobre balsas ilegales como esta maniobra
das por contrabandistas cientos de
migrantes centroamericanos intentan
cruzar el río grande buscan llegar a
suelo estadounidense en el tramo
conocido como romá en texas
los que tienen suerte lo logran pero los
que no se entregan a las autoridades
como ellos que agotados y con sus
pequeños a cuestas se dieron al hambre y
el frío
tras rendirse son trasladados a refugios
como este en donde el mer maldonado un
solicitante de asilo hondureño de 40
años recuerda cómo intentó atravesar la
frontera con su hijo isaac él se motivó
y
y gas y cosas él viene siendo activado
cuando mira cositas bonitas de día y
desde cuando escucharon ruido tan fuerte
le da miedito solo en la última jornada
al menos 30 hondureños como elmer fueron
guiados por un alguacil para entregarse
a la patrulla fronteriza pero la
situación más crítica la afrontan los
menores no acompañados a medida que
siguen pasando desde méjico los centros
de atención empiezan a llegar a su
capacidad máxima en medio de esta crisis
que la administración de darden le
achaca al pasado gobierno
el presidente trump separó a más de
3.000 niños de sus padres y en 2019
tuvimos el mayor aumento en décadas así
que hay muchas razones por la que los
niños deciden migrar estamos enviando un
mensaje muy claro la gente debe quedarse
en sus regiones
mientras localizan a sus familias
algunos de los jóvenes que permanecen en
este albergue de carrizo springs
intentan refugiarse en el fútbol y así
olvidar por momentos la violencia y la
pobreza que los llevó a migrar
corea del norte pero este jueves dos
misiles balísticos de corto alcance en
el mar de japón la segunda prueba de
armas en una semana por parte de kim
jong-un
nuevos ensayos de misiles que llaman la
atención según el estado mayor conjunto
surcoreano el ejército norteño lanzó dos
misiles de corto alcance de la madrugada
de este jueves algo que las resoluciones
de la onu si castigan en el caso de
corea del norte
expresamos nuestra profunda preocupación
por los últimos disparos de corea del
norte de lo que parecen ser misiles
balísticos de corto alcance en medio de
los diversos esfuerzos de nuestro
gobierno por alcanzar pronto el objetivo
de la completa desnuclearización de la
península de corea
los proyectiles llegaron en aguas del
mar de japón recorrieron una distancia
de unos 450 kilómetros y alcanzaron una
altura máxima de unos 60 kilómetros
desde este jueves es el segundo ensayo
de armas que realiza el régimen en una
semana tras probar dos misiles de
crucero el pasado domingo según expertos
esta maniobra es una señal de que
pyongyang quiere un diálogo serio con la
nueva administración estadounidense the
job air en
cada vez que una administración llega a
washington intentan adoptar una posición
fuerte es una especie de táctica de
negociación así que creo que esperábamos
este tipo de actitudes
en el pasado de enero el líder
norcoreano kim jong-un y ya instó al
nuevo gobierno de job airén a proponer
nuevas alternativas para poder retomar
pronto las conversaciones sobre la
desnuclearización al país empobrecido y
golpeado duramente por la pandemia no le
interesa un enfoque paciente sino ir
elevando la atención regional de cara a
poder sentarse cuanto antes a negociar
una retirada de sanciones
hasta que el informativo muy buen día
[Música]